maybe michael we can start with kind of
a one-year update from when you actually
decided to make that uh decision and how
things have been going so far well if
you roll the clock back
to july we had 500 million dollars of
capital in our treasury we were holding
short dated treasury securities and
generating effectively like 20 basis
points of yield on it we've seen a
k-shape recovery
wall street came back with the vengeance
main street was
was flat on its back it was clear
there's monetary inflation so we decided
that we
were going to lose a large portion of
the 500 million in purchasing power if
we didn't do something my forecast then
was probably like 25
inflation like and you could have got
there just by looking at the s p index
so i thought you know 500 million minus
25 like losing
125 million dollars in 12 months
is kind of like losing money at 2 to 3x
the rate that the 2000 people in the
company were making money
so
we either needed to give the money back
to the shareholders
or we needed to invest in something so
you know the thought was well
if we're a company straw a main street
company struggling against all the
lockdowns with all the uncertainty and
we
are doing it minus 500 million dollars
yeah it feels like a university giving
up its endowment as it goes into a
crisis right so that
decapitalizing the company
it it was a way to give the 500 million
of shareholders they would have put in
the s p 500 and they would have got 34
percent on it
if we had done that
but we would have in essence left our
ourselves defenseless without any
capital
so
that was one strategy the second was
invested all i would have bought 500
million worth of bitcoin if
if i was a private company i just would
have walked out
bought all 500 million i would have done
it at whatever ten thousand dollars a
coin
but as a public company you got to think
about your outside shareholders
and you can't it's not like there's 10
you can't just go to the tent of asking
what they want to do and get their
buy-in when you're public
you've got a shifting set of outside
shareholders that are changing every
minute of the day when the stock market
is open
so the way that you actually handle this
is a bit more
more
sophisticated what we did is we
transparently
we telegraphed that we were looking at
this our first press release was an
announcement that
we were going to
buy back 250 million dollars worth of
our stock over the course of 12 months
and we were going to invest 250 million
dollars of our capital in hard assets
and we said we're looking at everything
under the sun and bitcoin was one of the
things
so i
my first love of the bitcoin community
was that the way that i knew i liked all
the bitcoiners was
was one day later some
cyber hornet some bitcoiner goes
microstrategy is considering buying
bitcoin with 250 million dollars
now as bitcoin merged in there with gold
silver commodities equity property real
estate anything you could have imagined
but the bitcoin community immediately
picked up on that i don't know how they
do that right they must be scanning for
this
nobody else picked up on it the stock
was trading 120 a share a week goes by
literally you announce you're going to
spend 250 million dollars and buy your
stock like you think it would move nope
crickets but the market had a week of
notice and then a week later we stepped
it up into the next gear which is okay
we're gonna buy 250 million dollars
worth of bitcoin we made the decision
we're not splitting it across six assets
right
and it's a good thing we did right
because uh bitcoins up 332 percent in 12
months gold is down
7
if we'd split it 50 50 125 million of
gold 125 million of bitcoin
right it would have cost us billions
if we'd gone all gold it would have cost
us many many many billion billions we'll
come back to that in a second
so so we had to do something but the
question is what so we just picked
bitcoin we made the decision
but we thought this is going to be
jarring for some people
stock is around 122 at the time
right to put this in perspective the
company's 500 million dollar revenue
generator generating cash flow
and um we have more than 500 million in
cash
and about 10 million shares so the
company's trading at one times revenue
plus cash
we give back all the cash the company
trades at one times revenue the stock
goes to 60 bucks a share
right so we're like 122 no one's really
paying attention but we said well maybe
people think this is offensive they're
not going to like this or it's too risky
how do you actually orange pill
every one of your outside shareholders
at the same time
well you can't
so
the next best thing is we just offered
to buy them out
so the idea is if you don't like this
we're going to buy buy you out we're
going to post 250 million dollars to buy
back shares at a premium
so we offered to do the buy back at up
to 140 a share
which is you know
buyout premium if you don't like it then
you sell your shares back to us at a
profit
we wait 20 days
so the market trades for 20 days and you
know in the first week the market's
trading on 135. like people so they're
not even they're not even quite sure
about the bio then after after a while
they start thinking they're like well if
i can put it back to the company at 140
then presumably
maybe it's worth more so the stock
trades up a bit past the 140. and at the
end of the tender period we have uh
about 60 million dollars worth of shares
tendered
everyone that didn't like the strategy
at 20 days of selling to the open market
and if you sold in the open market above
140 then why wouldn't you and if you're
still holding the shares at the end of
the tender period and you don't like the
strategy you sell under the tender
so the result of the dutch auction is we
had 175 million dollars of extra capital
you know
we thought about it we put another press
release
okay this is our primary treasury
reserve asset
so the the first notch was this is a
treasury reserve asset
the second step is this is the primary
treasury reserve asset then we bought
175 million more bitcoin so that point
we're up to 425
million uh the first tranche is in the
11
500 range
uh that was that was a little bit
difficult it was more difficult to do
the second tranche because bitcoin
traded down we had a loss it traded down
to like you know into the tens and even
yeah you remember that so the second
tranche we bought at ninth at 000
something
uh because we're committed right and and
you know if you go pull the twitter
stream there's all sorts of interesting
commentary on our our you know
strategy